this is an address honoring Thomas
Jefferson he Wilson said this was a
address to the Jefferson Club of Los
Angeles in may of nineteen eleven
speaking of Jefferson and his authorship
of the Declaration Wilson said if you
want to understand the real Declaration
of Independence do not repeat the
preface if you want to understand the
real Declaration of Independence do not
repeat the preface what do you mean by
the preface the preface you know those
first couple of paragraphs the part
about all men have are created by God
with certain inalienable rights among
which are life liberty the pursuit of
happiness that this is the securing
these rights is the purpose for which
governments are instituted among men
don't repeat that part Wilson told us in
1911 now if we don't repeat that part
what are we left with in the Declaration
and this you know it's left with with
most of it but most of it is the litany
of grievances against George the third
right in other words we're left with
those specific problems that the people
at that time faced so if government is
basically all about adjusting itself to
meet whatever new problems history
presents so declaration presents a set
of specific problems here's what they
are in 1776 and the notions of
government there in the preface are the
particular answer at that time to those
particular problems when the problems
change what's the logic tell us then the
notion of government must change as well
that's Wilson's basic point
I